الو
الحمد لله وصلت عالميا مش انا رحت عالميا
والا عالم كلهم جواني عيوني يقول لنا
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم معاكم شمس القصابه صاحبتك
هاي شموسه منتوجات الشموس في السوق واقف
اليسرى
[موسيقى]
تحديثاتنا نحن مثل ما انت شايفه يعني حين
ما شاء الله يهون من اللي جايين الزوار
سياح لعيبه
تروحون تشوفون كلهم بداياتي
وانا صغيره كنت احب اااه هوايه التجاره
لان جد وجدنا قانون تجارتي سوق واقف دخلت
معرض اسرى العصريه
12 نوع من البهارات المخللات ب 500 ريال
وطلعت من المعرض الاسره العصريه عشره ايام
باثنين وثلاثين
فكرت انه لازم يكون عندي دكان في البيت
مستحيل اروح الانستغرام
استنيت سن اربع سنين في البيت سمعت انه في
السوق واقف يوزعون بكاكين حق الحريق سوق
الحريم يسموها
اتصلت في المدير قلت انا شموس وين انت
شموس تعالي راح ندور عليك
ديكور خلال عشره ايام تجيبين اغراضك اواخر
شهر كامل
ده انا اسم همم الطريقه الخبز يا طريه
كل فخر من كثر حين مستانسين لنا كاس
العالم ما حسيت بالتعبين التعبي مثل بشوف
يوم هتشوف الناس الجماهير تشوفهم لمصايف
الليل احنا متواجدين من الصبح مصايف الليل
موجود في السوق واقف عشان الراوي العالم
نيون هنا نرويهم اكل القطري ضيافه قطريه
همت لك قطريه وبس
الحمد لله الحمد المطعم هذا
المطعم على المبسط يعني مطعم متواضع يعني
ما نقدر نقول انه بيكون مطعم عالمي صح ولا
لا لكن عالمي العالم زاره المطعم دول
العالم من كبر الشخصيات والامارات
اشجع بلدي اه اشجع ضيوف قطر كلهم الا
يستاهل بياخذ الكاس الا اخذ الكاس نجاح
نجاحنا
[موسيقى]